en el vídeo pasado vimos a un óvulo de
nuestra madre fusionarse con un
espermatozoide de nuestro padre para
formar así un cigoto el cual continuará
replicándose y se convertirá en nosotros
así que si dijéramos que este es el
espermatozoide de mi papá que se fusiona
con el óvulo de mi mamá
este cigoto continuaría replicándose
hasta convertirse en mil y luego ya ves
hago un vídeo acerca de fertilización y
cómo sucede esto bueno pues es justo lo
que vamos a ver en este vídeo recuerda
que el cigoto tiene un número diploide
de cromosomas y una vez más nos
referimos a esto como 2n donde n es el
número aplaude y 12 en el número
diploide y en el caso de los seres
humanos n es igual a 23 y por lo tanto 2
nm esto va a ser igual al doble a 46 y
bueno justo aquí tengo el conjunto
completo de cromosomas
es decir los 46 cromosomas y date cuenta
que aquí obtuve un cromo
de mi papá y un cromosoma x de mi mamá y
justo esto hace que yo sea un hombre y
bueno después que va a pasar
bueno pues para ver esto déjame bajar un
poco la pantalla porque vamos a hablar
de qué va a pasar en este vídeo me voy a
quedar con esta parte de aquí y este es
el voto que tengo aquí continuará
replicándose debido a la mitosis así que
voy a ponerlo así este circuito que está
aquí va a entrar en mitosis 1002
sí y bueno no quiero especificar mucho
acerca de la mitosis en este vídeo sin
embargo quiero que te des cuenta que
ahora voy a tener dos células dos
células y voy a intentar hacerlas un
poco más pequeñas recuerda esto no está
escala pero lo voy a intentar hacer un
poco más pequeño para que quepa todo lo
que quiero explicarte en esta pantalla
en este pesaron y ahora estas dos
células que tenemos en lugar de dibujar
todos los 46 cromosomas voy a poner en
su núcleo el número 2 n es decir el
número de play de 2 n ya está también va
a tener 2 en el número diploide justo
así entonces cada una de estas dos
células sigue teniendo el conjunto
completo de cromosomas esto es
esencialmente lo que hace la mitosis
replica completamente a las células por
lo que las células tienen el mismo
número de cromosomas y bueno este
proceso seguirá sucediendo y va a seguir
sucediendo
de tal manera que estas dos células
continuarán replicando
cada una por su cuenta y entonces va a
pasar lo siguiente gracias a la mitosis
es decir que aquí nos estamos fijando en
otra ronda de la mitosis de la mitosis
lo que va a pasar es que estas dos
células van a duplicarse y entonces
ahora habrá cuatro nuevas células dejar
ponerlas y 1 2
4 y cada una de ellas tendrá un número
diploide de cromosomas es decir que cada
una de ellas va a tener 2n cromosomas
adentro está también 2n está aquí
también 2n un numero diploide que
recuerda que en el caso de los seres
humanos
este número 46 2n y bueno eso fue en la
siguiente mitosis ahora estas cuatro
células que tengo aquí de nuevo van a
entrar en mitosis y de ahí van a salir 8
células y así este proceso continuará
pasando y pasando y pasando y pasando
por eso voy a poner aquí estos puntos
suspensivos para que veas que sigue
pasando y pasando la mitosis déjame
ponerlo por acá la mitosis va a pasar
muchas veces me too si es muy bien y
todo esto hasta que tengas mil células y
después miles de células después
millones de células y después diez
millones de células qué sé yo así que
déjame dibujar por aquí
un montón de pequeñas células que son
ahora todas las células que tienes
después de que hayan pasado muchas veces
la mitosis después de que haya pasado
muchas veces la mitosis a déjame poner
algunas más a otras por aquí y aquí ya
tengo cada una de estas células que por
cierto cada una de ellas va a tener un
número diploide de cromosomas cada una
de ellas va a tener 46 cromosomas en los
seres humanos o 23 pares homólogos y
bueno ahora tenemos esta gran esfera
llena de células después de que ha
pasado muchas veces la mitosis pero
ahora va a pasar algo muy importante
estas células se van a diferenciar en lo
que soy y para eso estas células se van
a diferenciar en distintas partes de mi
cuerpo por ejemplo se me ocurre decir
que esta célula de aquí y esta y ésta y
esta de aquí y además bueno van a
continuar replicándose y toda su
descendencia van a formar lo que va a
ser
así que voy a poner estás por aquí se me
ocurren que éstas se van a diferenciar
en las células de mi cerebro vamos a dar
otro ejemplo se me ocurre que estas está
aquí está aquí está esta esta esta todas
ellas y su descendencia seguirán
replicándose y después de varias fases
de mitosis más puedo decir que van a dar
lugar a las células de mi corazón se van
a diferenciar en células de mi corazón y
bueno puedo decir que también no sea
ésta y ésta y ésta y ésta y ésta y ésta
y bueno esta y esta y están todas ellas
y su descendencia eventualmente darán
lugar a las células de mis pulmones y
por supuesto eventualmente se van a
diferenciar en todas las distintas
células que hacen que yo sea yo y bueno
después va a seguir habiendo muchas más
mitosis así que lo voy a poner así
unos puntos suspensivos y bueno me voy
para acá algo más o menos así voy a
poner que sigue pasando el proceso de la
mitosis ni tú si es hasta que en un
momento y para eso déjame bajar un poco
la pantalla vamos a tener completamente
a un ser humano así que aquí voy a poner
mi dibujo de un ser humano o lo mejor
que me salió un ser humano lo voy a
traer justo por acá sé que no se parece
mucho a mí pero tiene mucho cabello como
yo y bueno también tiene grandes cejas y
aunque sigue sin verse como yo de igual
qué manera tú entiendes que bueno este
es un ser humano y aunque esto
obviamente no es mi mejor representación
de un ser humano espero que tú tengas la
idea de lo que va a pasar y bueno claro
no estoy tan marcado como como este
personaje de aquí en fin a lo que quería
llegar es que poco a poco las células
irán diferenciándose hasta formar un ser
humano y entonces va a pasar lo
siguiente estas células que había puesto
de este color rosado bueno van a ser
después células de mi cerebro
voy a poner por aquí tengo bastantes
células de este color rosado se van a
diferenciar en las células de mi cerebro
y después estas las que tengo de color
blanco había dicho que se iban a
diferenciar en mis pulmones así que los
voy a poner por aquí voy a poner muchas
de estas
células de color blanco y bueno también
por acá tengo algunas de estas células
de color blanco algo más o menos así
porque se van a diferenciar en mis
pulmones y recuerda obviamente esto no
está escala porque las células son muy
pequeñas para que se vean pero bueno
esta otras células que tengo aquí se van
a diferenciar en las células de mi
corazón así que las pondré por acá en
las células del corazón se va a ver más
o menos así ahora aquí quiero hacer una
distinción muy importante porque la
mayoría de las células que dibujé aquí
son productos de la mitosis estas son
las células de tu cuerpo y todas ellas
son conocidas como células somáticas es
decir que las células de tus pulmones
de tus pulmones también las de tu
corazón y bueno las de tu cerebro y las
de casi todo tu cuerpo son conocidas
como células somáticas así que le voy a
poner aquí se lo las
y gas y bueno tal vez después de esto te
estás preguntando lo siguiente y para
eso
déjame subir un poco esta pantalla cómo
es que luego obtenemos estas células upl
hoy ves cómo obtienes estas células
sexuales es decir si estás hablando de
un hombre
estos gametos son los espermatozoides y
si estás hablando de una mujer
estos son los óvulos en ambos casos como
que tenemos estas células sexuales es
decir estos gametos que tienen un número
aplaude y la manera en la que sucede si
regreso el dibujo que tengo acá abajo la
manera en la que sucede es la siguiente
algunas de estas células que tengo aquí
se van a diferenciar en células
germinales así que imagínate que está
esta está esta están esta y esta se van
a diferenciar en células germinales y en
tus cornadas y en el caso de una mujer
las gónadas son los ovarios los ovarios
déjame ponerlos así en déjame escribirlo
estos son los
varios
bah
dios y en el caso de los hombres bueno
las gónadas son los testículos son los
testículos así que lo voy a escribir
aquí son los testículos de ti y los
perfecto y bueno las células germinales
en las gónadas es decir estas células
que ya se diferenciaron y están en los
testículos y en los ovarios van a
producir los gametos debido al proceso
de la meiosis así que debido al proceso
de la meiosis
si es por medio de este proceso los
ovarios van a producir los óvulos déjame
ponerlo así van a producir los óvulos
los mientras que los testículos van a
producir los espermatozoides de gen
escribirlo los espermatozoides
yo soy bea y esto nos saca a relucir una
cosa muy importante porque es la
biología
hablamos de mutaciones y selección
natural y muchas cosas más bien es
importante darnos cuenta como las
mutaciones te afectan a ti ya tus hijos
si tienes una mutación en una célula
somática no se digamos aquí en tus
pulmones o en tu corazón o en tu cerebro
o en la piel o qué sé yo esto puede
provocar una cosa muy peligrosa como el
cáncer y bueno si sucede que no te da
cuando eres joven y logras tener la
oportunidad de reproducirse
lo que quiero contarte es que como esto
sucede en tus células somáticas no
afectarán al adn que heredarían de ti
los hijos que pudieras llegar a tener el
adn que heredarían de ti dependerá de lo
que sucede en tus gametos pero si sucede
una mutación cuando se están
diferenciando las células de tus gametos
no sean por ejemplo esta de aquí
y éstas continúan replicándose y poco a
poco se están diferenciando en células
gam éticas entonces la mutación está ahí
y a través de la meiosis se producirán
espermatozoides con una mutación y aquí
si existe una probabilidad de que ésta
pase a tus hijos pero puede ser que no
todos los espermatozoides tengan la
mutación y si recuerdas lo que vimos
justo por acá arriba en esta parte de
aquí entonces quiero que recuerdes que
puede ser que el que tenga la mutación
sea 1 entre 200 y 300 millones de
espermatozoides y esto hace de alguna
manera que sea mucho más difícil que ese
sea el espermatozoide que se fusione con
el óvulo puede ser que ese
espermatozoide no se funcione con el
óvulo o en su dado caso que algo impida
que el espermatozoide nada por el fluído
y bueno puede ser que no lo logren las
mutaciones sólo afectan a tus hijos
cuando estas mutaciones suceden en
células que eventualmente se van a
diferenciar en
y que darán lugar a tus hijos